hey guys it's Tuesday my name is Jeff
I'm Dan and we're here to get you all
caught up on the latest gaming news also
yes I am this much fun than Dan even
wearing 6-inch heels come on
yeah
today's biggest story is probably the
SNES classic creoles opens pre-owned is
closed again and we got some new info on
what the console is going to feature
here's what we know
much like the NES classic the SNES
classic pre-orders came and went in the
blink of an eye several of us at
GameSpot tried our hardest to secure one
but we were unlucky
unfortunately scalpers have already
taken to listing their systems on eBay
with some going for as high as $300 it's
worth remembering before you better
week's rent though that Nintendo have
promised to quote produce significantly
more units of Super NES classic Edition
than we did of NES classic edition so
fingers crossed we all managed to get
one when the next wave is released the
SNES classic Edition launches on
September 29 and will be available until
the end of 2017
another SNES classic news Nintendo have
released a trailer that showcases the
system's features most notable is the
rewind feature that allows you to rewind
your game at any point the trailer
showcases the feature being used in
super punch-out to retry a fight after
being knocked out the feature will also
use your saved game play as a screen
saver when the system is left idle
you'll be able to apply three different
filters to your games as well I see our
to filter for that classic cathode ray
tube feeling 4:3 aspect ratio for all of
you squares and a pixel perfect version
of the cutting-edge graphics let us know
how you went with pre-ordering an SNES
classic and what game you're most
excited about syncing time into next up
the dragon bull fighter Z fighters head
fight it is I think it's father's honor
anyway not sure I know I know the dragon
pool special edition has been announced
as have the pre-order bonuses and if you
need a little incentive to pick those up
registration for the closed beta has
also opened fan dynam Co unveiled with
the $140 collector's edition which
includes a copy of the game a 7-inch
statue of Goku that features quote
exclusive manga dimension coloring a
steelbook case and three artboards as
for what you'll get if you throw your
dollars in early pre-orders will be able
to get two exclusive lucky avatars and
two early unlockable characters the
recently revealed Super Saiyan blue Goku
and Super Saiyan blue Vegeta if you're
keen on trying your hand at the game you
can now sign up for the closed beta
which will run on ps4 and Xbox one from
September 16 to 17 Xbox users can sign
up through the Xbox insider program
while ps4 players can register by
visiting bandai name
website Dragonball Fighters Z fighters
whatever whatever it's called is that
for ps4 Xbox one and PC in early 2018
it's been far too long since I've been
able to talk about Rainbow six siege
let's change that here's the details on
the three new operators and the new map
that's coming as a part of the blood
orchid update first up all players of
Rainbow six siege will get access to the
new map theme park the new map will see
you breaching the walls of an amusement
park with areas that look like a ghost a
train and a candy bar very cool on the
operator front the two new Hong
kong-based characters are defend Alicia
and attacker Lane Latian packs goo mines
that when stepped on inject enemies with
poison affected enemies can remove the
poison needles by following an on-screen
prompt but doing so leaves them open to
attack lesion can plant seven mines but
these are crew over time so he doesn't
start a match with a full stock ling on
the other hand will be packing spheres
that launch blinding flashes into the
air called candala the gadget can be
tossed or rolled like a grenade and
attached to a breacher bull surface so
that they go through and detonate on the
other side the third operator is the
Polish defender Ella whose mines
disorient and stun enemies
she can also detonate a mine on herself
when she's down to deter attackers from
finishing her off ella is available
after the games planned polished themed
content was canceled so you yourself
could roll out operation health in order
to fix many of the game's shortcomings
the second polish operator will be
available in the next season of Rainbow
six siege content themed around South
Korea operation blood orchid doesn't
have a concrete release date but Ubisoft
have said they're planning on rolling
out the new update on September 5th and
that's everything we have for you today
make sure you hit that subscribe button
so you can see us every day of the
working week bringing you all the gaming
news you'll ever need that's right and
doulas so what you thought of today's
stories in that comment box a we will
catch you tomorrow wait is it yeah and
all [ __ ] is like an apple orchard which
is ard yeah and orchid is like a flower
oh yeah but how do we know which this
one is it could be all good it could be
an orchard that's full of what yep it's
really don't